ja genau so ist es super weg ist hier
bei uns er habe ich das wahrscheinlich
beste ergebnis das die grünen jemals war
in der bund tags bundestagswahl erzielt
haben aber weit hinter dem handschuhfach
eine kanzlerkandidatin ins rennen
geschickt hat wie bewerten sie das
ergebnis genauso wie sie es gesagt haben
es sind schöne zuwächse aber so richtig
freuen kann man sich darüber auch nicht
weil natürlich mehr möglich gewesen wäre
wir hatten andere ansprüche wir hatten
andere pläne und die haben wir nicht
eingelöst also es ist beides ein schönes
ergebnis
im grunde ist aber auch egal ob wir
jetzt 14,8 oder 15,3 gemacht haben wir
haben die jungs chance wie werden die
ergreifen und dann hoffentlich die
regierung stark inter inhaltlich kriegen
aber die regierungs chancen sind
natürlich dafür eine koalition aber die
grünen werden deutlich der juniorpartner
sein wenn sie zehn prozent hinter sowohl
cdu als auch spd landen wie viel grüne
politik können sie deine arbeit aber
wenn man es klug macht dass politik
nicht malen nach zahlen da guckt man
sich die großen klecksen und zwei kleine
kleckse oder kleine hexe und haben dann
schaut auf die substanz und da glaube
ich haben wir einen beitrag zu leisten
der sich vielleicht aus den zahlen aber
aus den verhältnissen lebt die
verhältnisse bedeuten dass man die
politik ändern muss wir haben
konzeptionell weit vorgearbeitet
so eine situation habe ich persönlich
schon mal exakt so erlebt in schleswig
holstein auch damals am meisten ampel
möglich und ich weiß man solche
verhandlung führt wir können also in den
sondierungen wie auch in der regierung
ein unterschied machen und dass die
zahlen sind da jetzt ganz egal aber in
laschet und olaf scholz erheben beide
den anspruch einer regierungsbildung
sind parallele gespräche sondierungen
für sie aus sicht der grünen sowohl mit
spd als auch union parallel sinnvoll was
erstmal so logisch dass sie das sagen
müssen das erwartete ja nur noch ihre
basis davon mal gucken wie der abend
endet im moment gibt es eine leichte
tendenz auch das wird man abwarten
müssen zugunsten der spd
parallel komplette sondierung zu führen
oder kondition zur haltung zu führen
macht irgendwann keinen sinn mehr aber
erst einmal dass die verschiedenen
konstellation ausgelotet werden das
gebietet der respekt vor dem wähler und
auch die suche nach einer idee denn wir
haben ja nun eine politische lage wo
partei miteinander reagieren müssen die
nicht dafür gebaut sind das ist ja auch
für den bund eine neue übung auf den
ländern auf der länder ebene haben wir
mehr erfahrung das heißt es muss in
diesen jungs gesprächen gelegen zu
verstehen dass eine neue zeitrechnung
eingebrochen ist und ich würde sagen wer
von den beiden das besser versteht hat
mir ganz gute chance konto zu werden ist
ja eher die frage betrieben sie zuerst
in sanierung gehen würden auf jeden fall
mit dem wahlsieger der prozentual vorne
liegt
ich kann sagen wie wir das in schleswig
holstein gemacht haben da haben wir
zuerst mit der fdp gesprochen also erst
mal haben wir geschaut der grund ist
grün und fdp liegen ja auf der skala
denkbar breit bei sozial
steuerpolitischen fragen auseinander da
muss man sich erst mal klären ob es da
irgendwas verbinden es gibt gemeinsame
projekte und das hat sich heute schon
gut geklappt letzte frage wie schnell
sind sie zu gesprächen bereit jederzeit
kann heute abend losgehen ich nehme an
alle werden noch mal kurz die gremien
befassen das dauert ein paar tage aber
wir sollten sehen dass es schneller geht
als beim letzten mal also 2017 dieses
gebirge brauchen wir nicht noch mal im
land und den dank robert aber
tatsächlich erhöhen